it is a multi-user virtual reality
projection system so on this large
screen that you see here we display it's
really seen for up to six users and for
each of them we provide individual
perspective so that all so that all can
perceive the shared space from the
individual perspectives what you see
here is filmed through a camera like
years with shorter glasses on and the
cameras tracked as are the three users
that we see here interacting with this
world and since the camera is tracked as
all the users you can see you can
understand the pointing and tracing
gestures of the users and you also see
some advanced interaction techniques
that we developed here using the
metaphor photography to to travel
through virtual spaces and so on so I'm
not going into detail about that this is
really more about getting you an idea of
how our system works if you go through
the 3d cinema you get stereoscopic
movies that are rendered with different
views for your left and your right eye
now the distance between your left and
your right eye is 65 millimeters which
is not very much
Wallis when you move around this already
seated this is like about a meter when
you're walking around this is way more
and if you consider that more that that
that many people are sitting next to you
and a distance that you have to them
then you understand that the perspective
differences in between these people and
particularly if they move are far more
important than this there then the
difference between your two eyes and
stereoscopy for example a boss model
it's meant to be reviewed would look
like this from the left side from the
front it would look like this and from
the right the guy would see a picture
like that if you don't have that in a
common VR system you would have tracking
for one user only as for the left one
here he's pointing to something on the
on the bus model but you cannot perceive
what it is and you perceive the model
totally distorted as you're moving
around the screen this is what this
video shows so you see the perspective
adapts to his movements if instead both
are provided with the individual
perspective then you totally understand
oh okay I'm walking around this really
model and my colleague is pointing to
the right indicator of this vast model
all of a sudden this makes a shared
experience so all of a sudden you can
talk about these 3d models and discuss
geometrical features we have developed
very high frequency projectors that run
at 360 Hertz and they show the images
full for the different users one after
another
so basically Lin DLP projectors blue
green and red shown one after another we
have stacks of three projectors we used
a time slot to show images for different
users and then we doubled this with
another stack of projectors to get
stereoscopy this really allows you to
understand pointing and tracing gestures
of your fellow of your colleagues this
is a picture from a study that we have
done my colleague Andrew not to the left
of this image was pointing at individual
buildings that were predefined
and our participants had to identify
which building was meant and if you look
at this close you can really see that
they understand each other right we were
then thinking like okay if people travel
a lot who want to stay in contact in
best case we want to maintain
face-to-face contact here you see a
snapshot of what we have achieved where
groups of people at different locations
meet each other
in a virtual environment so these two
people in the foreground are locally
present while these two people in the
background do not look quite as good
because there's really reconstructed
they are captured in real time in 3d and
reconstructed as what we call 3d video
avatars with whom you can interact so
basically this is captured with five
Kinect from five different perspectives
and then we take the video the video
streams the color video streams and
adapt video streams
and use it to create a reconstruction of
a user by the way this is Stefan bag my
colleague who realized that it's pretty
much like this Star Wars hologram I mean
the reconstruction is there and then we
have to displace to show it so
immediately we have a situation which is
like the holodeck in Star Trek or the
all this in Star Wars these these
Holograms - again we were interested in
how pointing gestures work in this
environment and you can see it's a bit
more difficult right because the
reconstruction of the hand is not quite
as precise as you see you know my finger
here but we get decent results it's it's
not quite as good as as real word
interaction but it's kind of acceptable
interesting feature that you get out of
it when you work together in this shared
virtual environment and you use for
example a scaled-down version of the
world that you're that you're navigating
through as you can see here then you can
of course find yourself reconstructed in
this a 3d environment you see again here
people discussing details of this of
this miniature representation of the
environment that they are working in the
City Church of Weimar so-called heretic
area and when we zoom further and we see
all of us as miniatures represented in
real time we could do this forever
computer file video is brought to you by
the people at Harry's who make these
great shaving products I've used this
this morning which is why obviously I'm
looking quite as dapper as I am they
sell shaving products online and if
you've never heard of them they're big
believers in things being really good
value for money a lot of Shaving and
razors that you buy replacement blades
for and things are tend to be quite
overpriced this is the razor it's still
a bit of shaving foam on that is from
this morning you get some shaving foam
in this package some spare blades what I
really like is well it's got this case
to put the razor in when you're not
using it and I've got kids I wouldn't
like them to be hanging around sharp
razors so thanks to them for sponsoring
this video don't check out the website
and if you're interested in diving in
there then use the coupon code computer
file and that will really help us out as
well as you guys so thank you again to
the people at Harry's for sponsoring
this computerphile video check them out